[Music]
so
uh so good good afternoon everyone so my
talk is about uh how to assess the
reliability of
a deep neural network
so the scenario is as follows so you
have been training a neural network or
some
data and then the question is can you
rely on this neural network
so um
one one thing that everybody does is to
sorry
is to um check the generalization of
your neural network meaning that it's
generalization is the capacity the
capability of your network to operate as
expected on unseen data that has not
been seen during the training so if
generalization is okay then what is next
um maybe you want to to to stress
related with your system so you will
try to see whether it operates as
speaking on noisy or corrected data
just to stress the system a little bit
and maybe it makes sense because for
your application you are dealing with
noisy data for instance i am dealing
with images so images are
captured with a sensor and therefore
there is a
measurement noise and then these images
are
compressed to quantize and then these
images are transmitted to the neural
network so maybe there are some
incentives corruptions in the
acquisition chain
so if i'm happy with the rubbishness of
my network what's what is next
um
maybe
i would like to see whether interpreters
are expected on purposely perturbative
data so it's it's
this time it's me
me i will play the role of the
role of the adapter and really i will
i want to delude
my own system and see whether
our good it is our rabbit's
probabilities or safeties against the
purposely perturbative data
and is is
if unhappy with the safety so what is
next
so what is next is the formal proof and
then i will have a proof that my system
is operating as expected on any letter
any data that matters to me
so i will attack us on the example of
it so the digital network is
a box over there that uh
to find to identify the object
depicted in the image
so
everybody knows that uh in 2012 there
has been a breakthrough thanks to deep
neural network alex nets
and there is clearly a before and after
alex dance
so some say that this is the climax of
the artificial intelligence
oh then what would be generalization
deportation will be i sent it
by
looking whether they are quietly
classified so here my network is able to
find that there is a low mower in the
picture right the longest is what it is
well we have noise a little bit i will
check whether the
the prediction is still okay and if it
is i will add some more noise again and
again and again until the pressure the
predictions fail
and this is exactly the the turning
point here with a little bit more noise
then the prediction is wrong so we see
that the the network this network which
is the uh efficient net network is
pretty robust against noise addition
i can do the same with gp for instance i
will compress my image again and again
and again but until the network is no
longer seen alone nowhere and this is
the turning point again
so it's it's quite promised again giant
in japan
so what is next what is next is safety
then i'm playing uh the role of the of
an attacker so i i
am
really looking for the perturbations
that delude my system and here is the
result and we see that the distortion is
much smaller
so
maybe my network is not so reliable
and then the last step would be
certification i want i really really
want you know wherever
there exists
another example
which lies within a given distance here
is the closest uh example of these are
examples i could find and we can see
that the distortion is much much much
smaller than what was uh
experienced with
problems
so what is certification signification
can be defined as this so i have my
neural network f i will define an input
domain which is a region inside the
input space
put the
output which is the region to the output
space and then i will define the
property i would like to know whether
for any input data inside this input
domain
the the neural network
is
taking
a result is valuing
a resource which is inside this output
domain here
and if it is if it does then we certify
this function
so for instance for instance with my
image classification the input domain
will be something like this i have one
image here which is when classified and
then i would like to know whether for
all the images which are nearby meaning
that at a distance lower than epsilon
whether all these images are classified
as a panda so this will be my definition
of the input domain and for the output
domain it's just the all the
predictive probabilities such that the
class panda received the maximum
probabilities
so the goal of the certifier is to say
whether it is property which is defined
by a given network the input domain and
the output domain
is correct or not correct does it that
does this property calls are not
so um the 65 certifier can make two kind
of mistakes you can make false positives
meaning that the
the event
uh the the certifier will certify this
property whether the property does not
fall and there are also force negative
meaning that the event is not the the
certifier is not certifying whereas the
property there's a home
some people speak about soundness
meaning that there is no wrong
certification so the if the property
calls the ends
the certifier
um
uh sorry if the property does not work
then the certifier will never
certify and completeness means if the
property is called then the certifier
always certifies
and then there is
basically two approaches one approach is
the forward approach
where we try to see what is the uh how
this hypercube here is map into the
output space
so we are looking for the image of this
uh blue ice cube
and we will see here that the image is
not strictly included inside the output
domain therefore it means that somewhere
in this cyber queue there are images
which are not classified as combat so
the problem the property is it does not
hold but i can do the converse i'm gonna
try to see whether this uh output domain
is not back
into the uh image space
and for instance here in the range we
have all the regions of all the images
classified as founder and we see that my
blue hypercube here is not included
inside this set therefore they are
images and they are here they are images
that are not classified as founder
so uh
over the approach
so
formal proof belong to this approach and
we will consider a neural network
that the neural network is just a series
of transformation a linear
transformation followed by a non-linear
transformation followed by linear
transformation for and so on and so
forth
and then for each step we will see how
the ib cube is mapped into another
domain so with a linear transformation
it means that my amplitude will be
rotated and stretches along some
some directions
and then the learning gravity will
truncate
the the the corners here that are in uh
in the negative space
because the nonlinearity that i consider
here is just the rayleigh function the
rear activation function where anything
any neurons that takes a negative value
will be reset to zero
and this explain was why there is a
truncation here because that value here
will be negative so the array function
will reset it to zero
and the same for that
and then i applied the second linear
transformation which i want to have a
rotation and scaling around some
direction and then i will chunk it again
and again and again and it happens that
uh i was starting with an upper cube
here with one two
three four pieces and now i have a
polyethylene with one two three four
five six seven eight faces so there is a
really an explosion of a number of faces
and therefore it's not tractable to
manage
the description of such a complex
polyhedron
and this happens because any time that
the neuron can be active or inactive
then it means that i have a new facets
and therefore this problem is indeed it
can be complete
so what people do is that they are doing
some uh relaxation for instance they
will try to consider to manage a simpler
polyhedron like hyper rectangles and
then they will try to consider to find
what is the smallest hyper
hyper rectangles that contains this blue
blocks here
but therefore
the certifier is no longer complete
because at the end i will have a region
which is bigger than the image of my
blue iq
so that was to have some force negative
that was to not certify something that i
shouldn't define
so here are some papers about uh so uh
former proof so the very first one was
really x which is a sound and complete
but not really scalable you can only
apply this certifier on very small
neurometric and these are a purpose
about workstations
different uh
relaxation that allows you to
apply these certifiers and even
conversional neural network
you are more scalable
but then but then you are not complete
you are sound but not complete
what about the blackboard approach in
the background approach
it's typically the the safety uh
so i will play the role of an attacker
and i will try to
find what is the nearest
uh
adversary example so basically i will
apply australian attack like a cardinal
banner like pgd like ppe like or
whatever
which are all more or less are
making a gradient descent
to find an adversarial example
the problem is that this
uh attacks do not come with any
guarantee
so they find
adversarial examples but it's not clear
whether this is the nearest address or
example or not therefore those
techniques are not sound
they are complete but not sound
another uh idea is relaxation so
it's uh it's uh trying to uh uh finding
the map back of the output domain
and in this paper for instance with
parsley they are able to
find either plants
that are just below and above the
frontier locally around a given point
so here for instance we will find that
there exists images not classified as
panda
because the lower bound cuts the
umbrella
so this technique is sound but not
complete
and then our approach so approach is
very different we
we apply some method from the
statistical variability in generating
the name
and
we consider
we first consider a statistical
distribution of the input so basically
we say that the input is distributed
uniformly over the input domain
so which is quite strange because for
the moment there was no statistical
distribution involved
um
and then we will define the property of
failure so it's the probability that
the output of the network doesn't belong
to
the output domain
when x is distributed like that
and then we try to uh try to go to try
to measure this property of failure
and we say that if this probability is
bigger than a given level then it will
not certify
so there is clearly
some
adversary examples inside the new blue
hydrogen
the blue amplitude
and uh if
the probability of fear is lower than a
given
level then we will certify
so therefore we are complete but not
sound because for instance if
the private affair
is below the critical level but not
equal to zero then we will certify
something that we should not
but so it's kind of a relaxation of the
certification problem with hypothesis
testing
but the issue is now how can i estimate
a very small probability
because of course if this critical level
here pc goes to zero then my schemes
amount to a real certification
so i would like to have a level pc which
is extremely small therefore
i must be able to estimate the property
of failure and to compare it with this
critical level
so there was a very first paper a
provero which was using monte carlo
simulation the problem with monte carlo
simulation is that its inefficiency is
very very bad meaning that if i
if i if i want to
know whether the property of error is
around
10 to the minus line
then i must generate
billions of inputs
and um
indeed
uh there are tools which are much much
bigger than that
they are belong to the rare rhythm
simulation domain the main statistics
good luck important sampling process
fitting or this particular algorithm
that we use called last particle
so this part this algorithm is an
intuitive process managing very few uh
very
few samples and interactively they're
try to craft samples that directs the
properties
and basically the number of cores so the
complexity can be issues at the numbered
of course to the neural network and this
number of course is proportional to the
log of 100 pc so there's a log here
contrary to the monte carlo simulation
and this is really the game changer
more than that we have uh so this this
uh method is
complete but it's not sound but we can
control the sun yes so basically uh the
probability to have a force positive
would be lower than alpha something that
we can set that the user can set
uh
i can control and of course the lower
alpha the bigger the complexity
so i don't have any time to explain you
how the last particle algorithm is
working but we apply it on the
hue uh
scenario so basically you are
in this uh
plane and
to change your
direction because an airplane is coming
in front of you
and depending on the on speed on the
angles
and the altitudes of the
airplanes you should take a decision
and the decision will be taken by the
neural network so we should really
be sure that you can rely on this thing
so here are for instance runtimes where
we compare with iran iran is a sound and
complete
method
so you can apply it because the neural
network is is very small
and we can see that
our method is much faster than airbnb
however
our our
method makes some uh false positive here
so for instance we have been certifying
the neural network into a situation
where we should not have
done that
but what you should know about formal
proof is that uh an smt soldier like
iran takes four decisions indeed
maybe it will certify your property
maybe you will not certify your property
but so sometimes you just give up saying
no
the problem is too complex
and and sometimes you really try to
solve the problem and it takes too
long and then you finally
stop it
so
you can see that we have being able to
do that
just on a laptop
and we have a
a critical level which is 10 to the
minus
15.
so it's a super super super small
probability critical probability
another example is we apply our skin on
the image test
and then we cannot compare with formal
proof certified because they cannot
scale up to a convolutional neural
network that uh tackle
images from internationals
but so this time
we will play around with
npdrv android and http the critical
level is 10 minus 15 and this is
26 to the decision only nets which is a
kind of small correlation
metric and it takes 30 seconds to run
resonant 15.
and you can see here the average number
of calls
it takes so long because we have to
query the neural network
1400 times
and we can see also that as epsilon
which is the size of the abbey cube is
growing
then it takes less time because the
priority of failure is bigger so it's
easier to estimate a bigger probability
and of course we are certifying less
images
so our proposal is just just applying
statistical reality during the
environmental simulation to this
certification problem such that we can
scale better and to be fast
we
control the force positive so the lack
of sunniness with a given parameter
alpha
and we can apply this on a distribution
like this for uniform distribution over
the input demand but we can also
generalize to a
gaussian distribution or whatever
uh
moreover we can also apply this on the
uniform distribution over sphere
where a forward proof are not able to do
that
and
and indeed we are using the neural
network as with blackboards i mean we
are
we are not taking advantages of the fact
that we know that this is a different
network so this can be applied to techno
network it is nothing specific to them
it can also be applied to his vm random
forest near the nearest neighbor
classifier regresses whatever he wants
under some mild uh
conditions
and
so everything is explained in this
speaker that was accepted to lyrics this
year
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
time for a couple of questions
to start
what's up
[Music]
uh part of the bulk
so your
so you applied
your approach on the account in this
case
data
so where is the safety
side in this this application
and did you desire yes
and did you try other applications like
for instance
in autonomous driving where you have
safe constraints etc
you want a neural network to
compile the plane
so this
issue is quite pretty crucial
the damage of your data is small right
so we
surrender
the dimension of
the inputs
the dimension the dimension is very
small because
your your location the location of the
normal plane the speed and the angle and
the altitude so it's very few uh
parameters
so it's a
tensor of parameters
uh
whereas for images we have uh
hundreds of thousands pixel values
so this is the reason why we can compare
to formal proofs
and to see that we are making mistakes
at times we are making false positives
sometimes
but we never give up
and we never time out
the
to have some reactivity assessments for
really really large deep neural network
such as convolutional neural network
okay
you have another question
thank you uh
when you were presenting the result for
the
[Music]
problem
you showed that you had the value of
c
about 10 d minus 50 something like that
but when you compare it to
a hand
you have
like 10 10 percent of four positive
and the previous slides you had
something like
the probability of transpositive
should be less than alpha
so
i don't really isn't that kind of
worrying or maybe i misunderstood
the first positive of this hypothesis
testing so basically there is a force
positive here here the format is bigger
than the critical level and yet
i will turn the other the other way
around and so whenever
and this can happen if p is really close
to pc i would have a very hard time to
to know whether p is lower or
bigger than mpc
so there will be some force quality
that's at a lower
level than that
but this this is the first positive of
the the hypothesis test so there is a
coefficient here
and
here
for instance we have tested again and
again and again and again plenty of
times those nine
cases
and it happens that we always certify so
it's really the case where
the property of failure is lower than pc
but not equal to zero
so maybe you will take the risk say okay
10 to minus 50 is
never
never never happens so a bad event can
never happen so we take the risk because
yes there is
a valuation of the property but it's
it's the volume is slow tomorrow so the
property that happens
okay thank you is there any other
question or remark
also you can answer questions if you
want
how does it
behave in case of
the output space is not the convex or
not simply connecting
[Music]
but what you have to
resort to is is a scoring function
for any input i should have a story
function which tell me whether i'm about
to
uh to violate the property or not so
this scoring function should be a real
function give me a real
value
so basically for instance if it is
positive then it means that that will be
very classified if it is negative it
means that i will
be not well classified because the
classification will be wrong
so therefore
the last particle algorithm is driving
the
input data towards the
events
which is the valuation of the property
thanks to this scoring function which is
telling us where you should go that
direction because probably the other
examples are over there
but for uh we don't care whether the uh
uh
so whether the uh the map back of
um
[Music]
the output domain is convex or not
it's called x or not we don't care
provided we have this scoring machine
okay thank you i think we have to move
to the to the next presentation
um
okay thank you
thank you thank you for inviting me
as a thank you to you for the
presentation i'm going to
to continue your presentation but uh
in a
different perspective
one you introduce
it's a different verification so it's a
joint work with with the team
they've
artificial intelligence chair we have uh
inner wong in inside one with all the
guys
okay in the table
so some nice picture to begin with
because we are talking about attacks so
we're a bit tired it's the afternoon so
we need a nice picture
so the the picture illustrates uh what
is an attack
so you you receive mails with the
attack on text you just change
a
commercial okay this is just to fool
your spam detector
but you can also attack a
phase detection
identification system
by wearing stupid glasses
or you can try to attack a
person detection system by wearing this
patch here
then the system failed after recognizing
this
person as a person
so but you can also attack you mention
vehicles so you can attack autonomous
vehicles by
modifying
making little perturbation in the road
signs
by painting your car with special paint
and the system will recognize will
classify your car as a cake
and an experiment has been made also to
fool your tesla
that was the owner of the tesla
so you take these three and you just add
a noise here
like pinocchio
and the system recognized 85
it's problematic for the tesla
however it was the whole system and
some attacks has been made also by just
projecting false images in front of the
car and it was a mobilized system which
has been full by this system the mobilei
installed in the renault capture i think
nice picture
so uh we are going to to i'm going to
explain how to find a lesser example
so in uh if i take a teddy stalk this
exact method formal method to to prove
the existence of a of an um
example
so yeah since i will enter a little bit
more into detail i introduce some
notations
so i have a neural networks that takes x
x as an input you provide an output so
here the legal output is one
and r a is an attack or address io
example
and then it's just the same as x it's
not far from x the perturbation on x and
it will
the neural net will classify this
a as a form so you have attack a system
because you've just modified some little
picture excel on on the input image
and the output has changed
so to define the the adversarial example
you need three components
let me mention that of course you need
to find a validate example a and this
valid example
has to be close to
the the the point where you want to to
design your attack so you have to define
the distance so teddy told us about the
infinite ball around the point but you
can have two ball or whatever any kind
of ball this is the the distance or the
similarity measure on the
also
you can define a loss
at this higher loss to measure the
distance
the way you want to to
assess the fact that you have attacked
your system your attack is is a success
so of course when you dealing with
classification there is a very simple
thing
if the class the predictor class is
different from the the one the the one
you want then you you declare that the
system has been uh
attacked so in this case the loss is
just the difference between the output
okay
so teddy mentioned a lot of uh
approximation i call them heuristics and
he mentioned about
the critically uh wagner attacks or pgd
attacks so depending on on the ball
you're dealing with that is the distance
on the input some are more popular than
others so the most popular if you're
interested in l infinite ball is the pgd
and if when dealing with the l2 norm
with
binary or cw attack
it's the way or two of finding
an attack
so together with these heuristics you
have popular software such as cleverance
or art software that helps you to to
find to make this
system works
but here you'll find an attack but
you're not sure that it is the best
attack as a
teddy says
so
the the way to find the third example uh
that he focused on this third way the
robustness has a very efficient problem
proposed by cancer node but it turns out
that there is there exist other ways to
to see this problem and the first one is
to minimize the the vessel distortion
so the idea is to
minimize the distance
with the constraint that the
the loss also
is in some sense it allows
different view for instance here
we can play with infinite norm but we
can play also with l2 norm
within if need know we have a linear
cost we have that to know we have a
credit problem
but
they are
very hard optimization problems as we'll
see
and we focus on this formulation
so we can have a different formulation
with different guarantee if you minimize
the loss import deporting
it's a dual view you minimize the loss
and you you say you want to find see if
you find
another example within a certain ball
depending on the way you define that
is the point of view of the wrong cutler
once presented in icml in
208
so we are interested in this first
formulation minimizing a distance
with
a different output
so i have to precise some
uh
some uh to reset with maybe mention it
if you have a neural network this neural
network has a linear combination here
the the linear weights w and the linear
weights v but also we have this real u
which is non-linear and uncomplex
so the function
f
is can be modeled as zeta is the real u
of w x plus beta x being the input and
then the output f of x is v zeta plus
gamma
and here what is zeta the real u is the
maximum between h
and
zero so you can take this definition of
the function and rephrase your
optimization problem
but if i look at that i have two nice
things this is a linear combination so
it's a linear constraint
this is linear also so the ugly thing
here is the maxima between zero and one
because it's non-linear and convex it's
piecewise linear
so a way to deal with this piecewise
linearity it's a so-called radioplex
totally mentioned it also but i just
just enter a little bit into detail to
show you how it works if you want to
model this zeta maximum function
so you want to model this function
which is zero there and linear on that
part
so the way to do it in optimization is
to associate to each of these really
functions a binary variable
and you have a binary variable b
and you say okay if b goes to zero that
means i'm here and if b equal one that
means i'm there
and so
when you have that
constraint says zeta is maximum of h you
say okay
i will just
rewrite this constraint as four
linear constraints since they are linear
this is very nice
however
to write this linear constraint i have
to introduce this b here and the b is
modeling
the two cases because i'm piecewise ever
if b equals zero and here look if b
equals zero z has to be greater than
zero and smaller than zero that is equal
to zero
and if b equal one i am there
because b has um data has to be smaller
than h and since it's equal to one this
team whether is and smaller and greater
than x it has to be equal to h
so depending on the value of b i have z
equals zero of theta equal h
modelling this function
so i can rewrite take that and plug it
into the optimization problem
and i find this problem
this is the initial problem i want to
find the adversarial example close to x
so i want to minimize the distance
between x and r
with the constraint that the output
is not the desired thought so it's an
adversarial example i change the output
okay but what s is the output so it's
the
v data and zeta is the maximum here is
the pain because this is non-linear you
minimize here depending on p p infinity
it's linear p equal to it's quadratic
equal one is linear also piecewise in a
linear cost function here you have
linear constraints
but here you have maximum
actually here also
another difficulty but not so much so so
important so you reformulate that with
your four constraint
by introducing here be variable as much
as
this review activation function
so
you are happy because you have
linearized your system it's a linear
program
but you are not happy
because it's not a very nice linear
program because it's a linear program
but with continuous and discrete
variables so it's called a mixed integer
programming
it's a linear program with both
variables continuous and discrete
variables
and this is very hard as teddy says of
course this is a
npr problem
and
you have
the optimization issues and you have to
find the b and the to find the b you
have a combinatorial issue so you have
not only
optimization but combinatorial issues
you have to handle both
problems
so
i'm getting old now and when i was
studying
we are seeing this kind of problem in
the 80s and my professor at that time
says okay this is really untractable if
you see such a problem don't even look
at it you will never be able to solve it
but if you go through simple computation
with the progress in the understanding
of the problem the progress of computer
problems software the problem of
the progress is on solver you figure out
that now the computer we have the way of
dealing with this problem makes them
tractable
in some sense
and try to to see
how we we are going we can see this
problem and try to solve them
but we have to pay attention and try
to
to reformulate and to help the solvers
to find good solution
so how does it work to solve such a
problem
to solve such a problem because they are
binary
so the idea is to find two kinds of
bounds lower bounds and upper bound to
the problem
so the
lower bound first
it's a very simple relaxation you say
okay
i i i want continuous but i won't
discrete viable i don't know them
so i made a relaxation i said oh instead
of discrete i take continuous value
so of course this is not the solution of
my problem but when i find a cost it's a
lower bond of my problem so i know the
solution is not smaller than that
and then i'm going to make some choice
of some b
so maybe this b is zero or a1 i'm going
to choose which is the best one and then
i'll try with these choices to increase
my lower bar
and on the other side
i will fix some b choose some b 0 and 1
and then i optimize i solve this problem
with xb in a
and then because my b maybe they are not
optimal but i have an upper bound
here
and here again i will try to change some
b from one to zero and zero to one to to
put this
upper bound down
and this is the game of the optimization
you start with a lower
double and you go through the tree of
all possible beats and then you are
going to try
to make them
go together
because when the upper bound is equal to
the lower bound that means you have
found the solution of your problem
so um what's happened when you try to
solve this problem
sometimes it's
sometimes easy
to find an optimal solution for instance
here very easy this problem you find the
optimal solution because the upper bound
is okay
but it takes a long time to prove its
optimal because the lower bound has to
go through all possible combinations of
b to really prove that this is the very
best one
that means that
when the solver is well tuned and will
help you can find a nice solution very
quickly but it takes a long time to
prove that the solution is optimal
so
also you can play on some factors to
improve the quality of the solution
you can try to play on the
initialization of course if you have a
good idea on the solution you start
close to the solution you go faster
towards it
so initialization is a very
important issue
also you have to think about relevant
relaxation
and sometimes you add some constraint
and relaxation that helps you to
accelerate and
to think about the clever community
exploit exploitation of
the different solutions so we know that
very often the adversarial example is
very close to the example so the number
of activation that has changed from the
beginning is very small
so if you start with the b
of the initial example the number of
changes on your b is small and so so you
can accelerate and you can explorate the
solution so this is the way we are
working we are trying to see how to
improve this mip solver to solve bigger
and bigger problems
so um
[Music]
okay
so i go so i just give you some
empirical evidence of some experiments
we have made so we work on cfr
so it's smaller than imagenet
but it's bigger than the
air collision system
they are still in edges with a little
three-layer multi-layer perceptron just
with a regular machine not too big but
not too small
so we think we find 88
exact solution so we put a t max of uh
15 minutes
so within 15 minutes in 80 98 percent of
the solution we find
an adversarial example which is we prove
the
it is the very best solution of the
problem
and the computing time the main
computing time on this one example by we
use a solver called siplex which gives
the best results is
less than six seconds in average for
each example to find the proof that we
have a guarantee
so as an example if you find an
approximation you run kalini wagner
it's
much more faster but you just have an
approximation
here we have a proof exact solution of
the problem
and one thing we thought was interesting
uh so we we made the computation for
them to know
so
in other age we improve the solution of
the cardinality
which is something
on this small example
okay so
i just finished
the presentation saying okay we are
still working on this me trying to to
improve it and try to find the good and
nice relaxation
to to to have a more efficient system
capable of dealing with a larger image
and so on to work on the imagenet with
such an approach
thank you okay thank you
[Applause]
interesting
we do have time for questions
please
thank you very soon uh almost like 13
about the you said it's easy to find a
solution it's difficult to prove that
this is uh to set it to prove that it's
actually
wouldn't you or be better off with like
maybe um i guess
a certificate which is like true the
second probability
and then these would uh so for example
you would instead of going through all
the bees you tried to solve some bees
and just
[Music]
not exactly uh randomly you generate the
me
but
he
he made a smart a smart search
using uh pgd to improve the search of
the bees
and then solving the linear problem for
each
it has good result with this method
but it's not a
exact
proof
but
it discovered also that
the number of changes in these is is
reduced
so it's a reason why theoretically the
the combination may be ugly but
practically is not so ugly so if you're
clever in the way you explore the the
variation of the bees the activation
that changes
it's very interesting
so it's very important to the issue the
way that these are changing how to
monitor them how to find them
sorry i may have missed an information
or maybe it was not covered so i wanted
to ask regarding um the difference
between having an adversarial attack on
an image or on a certain data or and
like a fault being happened because of
noise or something like that is your
system able to differentiate between the
two different uh
scenarios or just you're considering
everything as an adversarial
example yes
we we focus on adversarial on attacks
because we want really to minimize the
distance
we're going to find the closest example
with this constraint that's all the
system if you think about the robustness
as teddy introduced you have to think
another age with some noise
and i've seen in some presentations the
difference between
shannon and amy so shannon is
considering robustness as overage or
something
here we are talking about someone wants
to attack you so it's specific design
noise to make perturbation so it's
different
and here in the presentation we are
already dealing with this specific noise
attacking the system so maybe it has its
own pattern which is different from any
kind of
specific noise designed to form
it's like a magic tour
it will be the last question yes thank
you stefan for the presentation so just
it's a remark
so there has been recently a very nice
library
introduced by
work by german people called robust
branch library so we are in the
robustness workshop and
there you you you can find the new
attack called the auto pgd so it is the
automatic pgp attack and it is much more
efficient than pgd so the paper
include was in ecma
recently and now it is becoming the
state of the yard to check robustness
and etc just um
thank you very much
uh
i think we are now moving to the from
okay so thanks very much for the
invitation and i'm very happy to be uh
remotely here
so i'm gonna take you in a journey in
robot's learning uh using the boss
optimization
uh so typically this will be a joint
work that we've done with uh
uh okay so
when when fedex asked me to give this
talk actually i i wanted to give first
an overview
of why provost um today has to do with
uh the result from maine and let's say
so we've seen uh different
point of views or uh
some differences and cover points
between presentations of stefan anthony
and i think that what i'm going to
present here are going to be a stretch
of the complement of what their uh they
have represented
so i'm going to be in the classical
supervised learning setting where
uh i'm going to take
a metric space typically it could be
even a polish space which is the data
space
z and with a metric d
and z you can think of it as the product
space of uh the input and the output
space x and y
and i'm gonna equip this space with the
probability measure
and uh theta would be my primary space
and on this i'm going to define the loss
function
which is basically a logarithmic could
be positive it's not a big deal and it's
going to be a measurable function in z
with respect to the measure rows neuron
and the goal is to solve this
minimization problem that you've seen
here in medium over theta which is very
always been mirror space
of uh some
risk which is expectation over uh the
measure row zero of my volts
okay
so when i do this basically what i want
as a desired property is that
uh to be
at least have some type of robustness
perturbations in the beta and radiative
uh solution about zero
and it turns out that as you all know
that your networks are vulnerable to uh
to the those perturbations adversarial
examples
where uh and personal uh perceptible
preservations today are maybe quite this
behavior called them all
and you've seen very nice pictures in
the photographs about behind for
instance
in fact many of us are examples of
defenses
that have been uh proposed um but the
problem is that many of these
dependencies defenses were either broken
or are computationally attractable in
practice or at least lack some
let's say guarantee
so in fact it is even challenging for a
ghostly identified class
classes of attacks to get to which one
can defend uh or even if they exist so
you've seen the talk for instance of
stefan where basically he has shown that
uh typically this problem can be uh seen
as any bihar problem in general uh for
instance through the length of formal
vertication
and uh we know that we still have a
reason hey
sorry sir
okay
uh and the recently we have seen some
convex reputations of this that have
started to merge however problems that
do not scale with large networks
so uh
is this story over uh in fact the full
implications of and mechanisms for the
versions of other certain examples are
not completely understood and so a very
active research area and probably there
are many many
mathematical
reasons which are involved up there and
uh we still
people are still trying to understand
what's going on there
uh so we have some explanations that
have merged uh typically that this may
be
a consequence of the structure of big
networks their ultimate linear structure
uh
so
and there is also explanation saying
that non-inverse features in big data
are actually responsible for uh
adversarial or
the lack of robustness so typically
these features are could be highly
predictive but brutal
and uh in fact there is also a lot of
likes research that say that even in
fact in classification adversaries
examples are even unavoidable
for certain high-dimensional settings
and there are two points of view to
explain this the first one is through
the lens of the construction measure
phenomenon in high dimension and more
precisely using tools from isometric
inequalities and basically what it says
is that if your data is suffered from a
concentrated metric uh probability
measure a space sorry it could be the
sphere the hyperview for instance then
any point will be susceptible to high
adversarial risk meaning that that point
would be either misclassified or
could be attacked
and this in fact finds its foundations
in the fact that for data which is
supported in uh such
spaces uh what we call absolute
expansions because basically we want to
see what are the consequences of the
perturbations and if you have a
perturbation of let's say some epsilon
and epsilon super positive then you are
inflating your regions by an amount
epsilon and this can blow up even for a
small percent
the other point of view is that of
interpolation so in fact if you take
your um let's say classification problem
as an interpolation uh a problem through
a matriculating classifier and uh if you
have some noise on the data but also in
the label then there's other examples
can become also unavoidable and what we
can say is also is that
the set of predictions may differ from
the ultimate classification this set is
a dense subset of zero one volume so it
is a dense subset however it occupies a
zero volume as the number of data steps
goes to infinity which leaves uh some
form of total
so in any way the existence and present
the pervasiveness
of these regular examples uh they all
point to the limitations of the standard
uh iid model
so uh what can we do
so the reason the the idea is basically
to quantify the impact of the adversary
by protruding data during the training
this is something that you've seen also
in the topic
so here first design presented a very
simple example where are we the two
moons and uh
this would be basically the standard
training
and the you see that near the edges or
near the
decision
region if you perturb a little bit here
or here then you're going to switch
basically the label of your points
either
and uh
so basically if you want to trade your
data maybe you can trade some accuracy
for robustness in which case you may end
up with some uh decision
region which is uh
right here and here basically you are
having errors
for sure however you're going to gain
insurance off the process and this is
basically the idea of contributing data
during training doing some adversarial
training
so we have several notions of research
and we started training the first one
and uh so here i'm going to focus on two
of them which are based on the boss
optimizations optimization sorry
the first one is what we call the
pointwise perturbation optimization so
typically i'm going to find here another
risk
which is the one presented here i'm not
going to take the expectation with
respect to uh
the uh so i'm going to take the
explanation back to row zero but now i'm
gonna perturb uh around all points which
are in the support of the distribution
number zero
so this is where i multiply my wrist
typically is that i'm taking here now
another loss which is
all the losses in symbol around the
epsilon metric theta
so this is something that we've seen
more or less increasing based effect on
the other hand uh
we have what we call this additional uh
perturbation optimization from vro and
in this case
what we're going to do is that we're not
going to put you up the data point-wise
we're going to contribute the the
distribution of the data so now i'm
going to optimize not
uh the the risk that i have before but
i'm going to optimize
the the worst case
the worst case risk that i had in some
ball around row zero in the metric d on
the probability uh space b which is um
so this is the second risk we're gonna
try to do so basically this is the holy
grail we want basically to allow the
perturbation of the distribution and to
optimize uh to minimize in the primary
theta the new risk which is the uh
duration of the original risk over the
ball uh or around row zero of a radius
epsilon
however the richness of the choice of v
will affect
both the richness and the uncertainty
set but also the trackability of the
resulting amount of solution problem the
main difference between these two
problems is that even if uh z here is uh
for nine dimensional this problem is
completely iphone dimensional okay
unless you are taking all the uh atomic
measures uh in with finite number of
atoms it doesn't make sense all the time
some approaches have been used in finite
dimensional parameterizations typically
constraints on the moment you support
the directional
deviations as a proxy of this problem
either we're using non-character
distances divergences for instance
between probability measures that as you
certainly know divergences are not very
stable for instance to
singular supports
and this is why people have been moving
to the vassar's line distance uh the
optimal transport business
which has become very successful in this
context and one of the main motivations
is that iowa unlike the other businesses
not divergencies the vaster steinball
around row zero includes distributions
with different supports supported are
different from zero and typically it
will allow to
learn uh from and seeing data
okay so
basically uh when you have these two
problems there are many challenges they
can uh they are both algorithmic and on
the learning uh
so i'm presenting here on the left the
diy problem and on the right the
pointwise version of it so the the right
hand side we can do things uh about it
at least from our our growth point of
view the left hand side is a little bit
more complicated it's even much much
more complicated because of the finance
structure of the optimization problem so
uh the natural question is can we relate
these two problems and in fact the
answer
can be true and there's certain
circumstances so for a line of class of
convex losses and costs we can convert
the dro to uh the
some sort of red rice upgrade for risk
minimization problem
and for a lot of class absolute losses
and costs we can convert again go to a
laboratory form of the uh pointwise
right the robust optimization uh
simulation so i'm gonna um cut back a
little bit uh in
a while to this one okay so in fact even
the
pro is very challenging to me in mind in
fact except for very specific cases the
inner non-complicated problem
is very attractive and it is even pretty
hard for instance if you look at the
problem involving non-smooth normals
with regular activations
the proposal we have made with the media
and lah is that in fact we can
approximate the arrow with prl
with some probable solid 8 and design
verbally conversion algorithms and the
idea is to use some smoothie
so let's get back here so typically what
has been done in the literature is uh
that it is the following uh let's say
relations between dro and pro for
instance it assume that l is continuous
then you have even this equality here
between the ro and the lagrangian form
of the pro so we have equality but now
you have to optimize over this
particular gamma which is not easy at
all and the supreme problem is still
very attractive
uh in other words people have
inconsenting and their other uh for
instance if zero
is
opposites
then you can have this pro relaxation
of dro and you have really uniform
approximation in n which allowed to
appeal to gamma convergence uh
uh arguments which is in benefit of
epsilon however we only have comparable
risk and the problem is that the the pr
problem is not inseparable in the n
variables and the square root problem is
still in the problem is still very
impactful
what we have have come up with is that
we can approximate indeed up to accuracy
epsilon at the
in the case where the loss is losses
continuous
and in this case we have your spawn
approximation however indeed it is
dependent on epsilon benefit anyway
we're not going to allow epsilon to be
very large so this is okay and we're
gonna tackle the inner problem by using
something
so for instance now the pro i'm gonna
change it to this guy
so people who are familiar with uh
optimization in china and they have
organized here that we have replaced
the pro and then with the supreme or the
max there we have replaced it with some
sort of logs on x where now the sum is
just an iteration so we're just
replacing our transition with an
iteration
okay and what we can prove is that the
dro can be approximately well
approximated with the smoothed pro uh
with a precision that is controlled with
tau epsilon and goes to zero as the next
one goes to zero on top of zero and uh
when we we can even relax spro by uh
replacing the iteration with sums which
we can implement in this case and in
this case we can also control the
difference between the two objectives
where now uh the rate will depend also
on the number of points that you sample
that doesn't depend on elimination uh
eventually
okay we have also control of the
gradient so if you compute the greatest
little guy here when you replace the
interval with uh with the sun then you
can prove
that with high variability or even on
the shoulder to be positive that the
gradient you're going to compute
will approximate what we call the clocks
of differential of the pro because this
even if l is uh differentiable the suit
of l is not different
and you can prove that in fact you are
in a ball or in a ball around your uh
clocks of sub potential and the radius
of the ball is controlled with town
and in fact
uh this gives you an algorithm through
sampling that not only will give you the
worst case adversaries but also a good
estimate of the subgrading for hgv so
for instance if you look at hdd you're
going to apply your hdd
in this case by taking the directions
which are dictated by this little
version of the
solutedrow
and what you can prove is that you have
conversions in this case of uh your
interest theta k
so they're going to converge around
let's say the critical points
but if you allow the temperature and the
number of samples the temperature to go
to zero and number of samples to go to j
with the number of integrations that
basically you're going to get to
integrate the point
of your original problem pro which
itself approximates below the dro
problem
okay we have many other guarantees
including generalization downs you
didn't do a punch rising regime uh of
course we don't have anything so far
in the overcrowded part
but we are still working on that
anyway just um coming here to uh
to the summary of my my talk
uh okay the field applications again and
mechanisms of the emergence of
advisories are not completely well
understood
i believe that it seems possible that
several mathematical effects combine to
produce adversarial examples not a
single one and this still nested a lot
of work
and
in fact
the common point of view of people
working in this is that their existence
and easiness of their
very similar examples point out points
to the limitations of the standardized
model
hence
the
robust optimization
lengths which offers a principled way to
get global guarantees
both in the computational algorithmic
side and this is our slide
there is much much to do in this area so
be typically what happens in the
non-smooth case for instance if you're
using gorilla
in your neural networks
so this is completely open
uh
well what about the feminine programs
which are completely
independent from the algorithm okay can
we say anything about the fact how we
did personal training compared to the
optimal training or even to the center
of training as a function of aslon
there are still i mean there are some
preliminary works on this
and uh also
as i showed you before basically when
you try to make your uh learning a
robust you're gonna create some accuracy
and in fact this leading effect of
robust optimization uh really still
needs to be well understood
and uh finally uh the guarantees that we
see most of the time are guarantees in
the underprimed price regime which is
the center generalization regime what
happens in the overheard drives regime
where basically uh uh deep northern
networks or even wide neural networks
properly which global maintenance for
instance are selected by robust training
algorithm and understanding for instance
the opposite for aggregation in the
inductive
of for instance he in the university say
is perpendicular
okay with this i'm done thanks very much
for listening
thank you very much
so i think we can take one one question
a question
just one stupid maybe question
there's no stupid question
so here we applied the transformation
log of exponential
abuse have you other
ideas to for instance to replace
the log with another function in the
exponential
another function
by for instance taking an increasing
function in the place of
so why
log an exponential
my question is so you apply the
transformation log and exponential are
there any other choices
actually this comes from a
regularization of this problem so if you
take the left hand side pro
you can write this as a supreme of over
probability measures which i suppose uh
supported in the ball of radius x1
and then you regularize this with the
covalent divergence
over absolutely continuous measures
which are dominated by the uniform
measurement and this gives you the log
okay so this comes as an interpretation
okay it comes from the character
the log sum
comes exactly from this and they can
okay thank you
so thank you again
thank you so we're moving to the to the
next presentation and we have we have
okay uh thanks for
uh
for you for the invitation for the nice
thoughts that we present to
this far so the stage has been sent like
perfect password the stage has been set
like perfectly for my presentation so
i'm going to
floss over some of the introductory
stuff i prepared
not knowing what would be the audience
for this presentation so i'll be the
pessimistic person i'm going to present
negative results
on robustness so like limits to what you
can do so it doesn't matter how much
globalization or this kind of stuff you
do there are certain limits which are
just fundamental
so okay yeah the compositing a photo
about a card going scroll or know how
that work
gives a cut if it works fine if you add
some noise or well crafted specific
noise so you can make it say
something as an answer for example and
the
the whole point is that this is this
persuasion is uh is very small and these
have very very uh real consequences in
real life you could derail the real api
systems for example doing things like
this
recognition or even more critical stuff
so
as we've seen some hints in the previous
talk uh
i guess examples require we thinking of
the whole
empirical risk minimization uh
part of the which is dominant in in ml
and also to making what it means to to
generalize what it means to predict uh
well on testing
okay so there are many types of attacks
uh most of the attacks you have seen up
to this point are uh so-called test time
attacks so the model is trained deployed
and then at test time
attackers could
modify the input to have uh
the model output or something else there
are poison attacks where
you could actually inject malicious data
into the training data of whatever
process training data to create a back
door which you can exploit during test
time okay and then of course there are
things that membership interests at that
way
you're interested in knowing if a
certain sample was used or not in
training a model okay
but of course we are going to stick to
the test time because that's the like
the easiest to understand a little
material perspective so it's an arms
race uh
people for
proposing new attacks
uh and people uh other people like
providing defense for that and yeah it's
been going on for a long time and last
time i checked this was like the
strongest
kind of attack
the seed of human
which is like
[Music]
in the talk of stefan okay something
which maybe we didn't it might have
slipped
this far it's not so it's not like
there's something wrong with the
machines okay there are some stuff which
is wrong machines but part of it is okay
just uh
uh the the the kind of inductive bias
you have on your perception might make
you
like a
feeling very weird way so for example
optical illusions you can think of those
as adversarial attacks which are not
happening in pixel space but in some
other space space of orientation so this
kind of stuff so humans are not uh are
not completely
safe from this they have a different
kind of inductive bias but it's the
stuff so basically uh uh
giving time constraints i'm going to
concentrate on only the first two parts
of my talk so i'm going to present
negative results for general models so
it's going to be as a result of a course
case of dimensionality or
a phenomenon whereby if you take a set
which is not too small in high dimension
and you inflate it a bit it's going to
feel the whole space okay or if you
normalize the volume
and then negative results for neural
networks which might be the new
highlight if some of you have seen
my talk so before
okay negative results so this is like
one slide to survive everything so it's
like a law
so the law says the butterfly effect of
misclassification so what are we talking
about if you have a classifier so
basically the classifier it's any map in
each other function from some
measure space so think of x
as a polish space so complete
minimizable separable that's mapping
inputs into uh uh uh uh
classes want to update like you may
think of image name with all the
different images
that makes errors or normal so this is a
classifier which is not perfect see on
the images of cats it misclassifies some
images of cats okay the law says under
certain
uh constrained structural constraints on
the
the the conditional distribution of cats
these small areas that you make on three
examples are going to transform to
a huge disaster
when you allow for people to pay you the
input okay so this is a law you can make
this
very formal
so one way to see so okay in certain
spaces so when i say second species
think of uh
of rd only to put like a gaussian
multivariate
distribution with
identical variants from one everywhere
or you could think of uniform
distributions here or any local cave
distribution or even a very more general
class of distribution for example if you
take any like a
positively curved
compact emanuel manifold and consider
the
the the unique uh
invariant measure on it so for example
in the sphere will just be the uniform
distribution on the sphere
uh then the following happens so if blue
the blue stuff here is the images of
cats which are misclassified by your
mother as being like say dogs but it's
like normal errors then you consider
this excellent blow up of this so you
consider the absolute neighborhood of
this set okay
so
saying that your classifier is not
perfect on images of cats basically says
this stuff has positive volume
okay
now you inflate it by epsilon you ask
yourself what's the volume of that
outside stuff because the one of the
outside stuff is the adversarial error
on average
that your classifier makes when the
attacker is allowed to perform inputs by
a valid epsilon and the whole point is
that on that setting
conditions on the space the probability
space on which this diagram leaves as
soon as this has positive volume
this guy is going to grow exponentially
in epsilon
okay so just
for the experts uh the the property that
you need here is you consider uh uh so
polish space
uh we equipped with with with the
measure and if that measure satisfies
the so-called telegram transportation
cost inequality then you're going to
have this butterfly effect take a small
set blow it up
then it's going to fill the whole space
basically saying that if you are not
perfect on normal examples then you're
going to be just so bad
when it comes to adversarial questions
uh yeah now of course if for example if
you argue this
using if you if you agree on this using
the r2 norm and then
by equivalence with the square root of a
square root of dimensional factors
if we do that to the l infinity num
attacks you get
uh an exponential uh dependence on on on
the dimension basically we are saying
this is going to go this stuff is going
to feel the space at an exponential
speed with respect to the dimension so
you're going to have a case of
dimensionality
uh okay so i mean all the talks you have
seen this well we have some intuition of
why by these things that happens for
example here i'm considering a problem
in which there's one strong feature that
has information
then there's a bunch of other features
which are annoying if you do classical
machine learning they're going to say if
maybe if i average this feature it's
going to give me maybe one bit of
information
many in terms of adversarial uh
considerations is very bad idea at the
same you want to only look at this
informative feature okay so in that
problem for example optimal attack is
just to
do nothing for this guy because there's
so much information that you do
something
the the classifier is going to detect
but these people because there are many
of them you can do
a small epsilon perturbation on each of
these other weak features and this is
going to change the class
level
okay so messages well i think we can
read it together
so address five examples are force of
nature so okay
we are going to come back to this in a
moment there are certain aspects of
addressing examples which are just due
to structural properties of the data
like if you have two gaussians
which have centers which are very close
it's difficult to say fight them they're
always going to be
a gray zone and this is not because your
classifier is not good it's because
that's that that doesn't work so when i
say the force of nature you should have
this analogy in mind try to separate two
gaussian that have centers which are
close okay there's a certain uh amount
of adversarial
vulnerability that not even the best
possible or possible they can can evade
so i mean you have you can also use an
analogy from information tiering okay
there's a limit to the
the rate that you can transmit the
information the noisy channel there's
also a limit to or how much you can be
and yeah there's certainly of course the
whole point is that
you should try your best to scrape this
limit but you shouldn't try to have
something that's 100 percent
additionally you doesn't make any sense
and okay okay this this stuff uh
uh uh resonates with some of the of the
talks so why do you do rather than
trying random stuff to mitigate uh of us
uh address our
reliability history there are certain
interesting other questions like out of
distribution the generation which
resonates with the dro
that the previous speaker talked about
and of course there is interesting
okay if we prepare this talk not knowing
what would be talked about by the other
people but of course there's stuff to be
done about verification and also
certification maybe you don't know
uh you really want to certify that this
cannot be a reservation and say hey i
know how to predict i don't know how to
predict it and you predict the wrong
level you can
certify and
this kind of stuff
okay so uh i'll talk about the second
kind of negative results
so negative results for know-how
networks so what i said before is
general so the classifier it was just
any measurable function
and adversary examples
came about into existence by just
structural properties of the space of
the features the classroom had nothing
to do with it except we just require
that it should be imperfect it doesn't
matter if it's a
random forecast or no one network it
doesn't really matter now here let's
zoom a bit into things and try to
understand whether
and depending on how you look at this
second part might be connected or
discriminated at the first part so okay
now we all know what's a no-handed one
to me you know what that work has only
one hidden
ear
it has all the complexities of what
of what we would see in in
in bigger networks so input layer output
layer input layer has d features
sorry input layer hidden the output
layer input layer has d features
the the hidden layer width so the number
of hidden neurons is k that's the weight
that's a very important parameter and
okay it's just a scalar non-network so
the input direction so you could think
of this as the number of pixels for
example the number of hidden walls and
and stuff
and okay so in another network so you
would have a bunch of stuff here you can
include symmetric w so it's like a
hidden width heating weights and you
would have one
uh scale up link here by which you
combine linearly the stuff together get
here you will have an activation
function like the world
that stephan
talked about
and these are the landable parameters
okay why do you create this you're
basically moving over this matrices and
moving over this stuff
okay so i'm going to consider uh
uh not general honor how networks okay
uh uh uh i'm going to consider neuron it
works in in in certain regions so these
are the so-called random features regime
in which you only learn
v and you cross w at the value of the
initialization so you could think of the
neural network as all of this is random
so you could see this as a random
feature map on which you do linear
regression
okay so you basically are doing linear
application on the random feature space
and the second case which is ntk okay it
will be too technical to talk about it
here but basically you linear heist and
one network that is value at
initialization and gives you a certain
feature about that it comes with the
stuff so all of these things are all
about generating random features
on which you can use stuff now if you
take the weight to infinity this is
going to correspond to or to kennels and
you can consider the the associated
producing canadian spaces and do
regression in these infinite dimensional
spaces
so uh
okay
i saw the the second so what the the
goal here is to understand the
robustness of know-how networks the
robustness or non-robustness of neural
networks in those two regions
simplifying regimes those regions are
simplified so we can actually prove the
stuff so consider data so this is a
random
labels and this data x1 up to x and a
sampled uniformly id on the units here
in g dimensions
and what is important here is that
the white eyes are not deterministic
functions of the x eyes so there's level
noise okay and we're going to put
ourselves in the interpolating regime
where we try to learn why to learn the
the labels from the samples so
in the previous talk
incidentally there was a paragraph about
when you're in the interpolating regime
with noise then you might
have it as a sense of actually you can
prove that
and uh yeah so
one thing which
important to us is like the the error at
training
and then the device acting on optimal
generalization for the problem okay and
this minus that gives you the amount of
overfit in your dream so if you if this
is smaller than the buyer's optima
generation at all it means you're
learning below
or on 20 seconds observing air which is
more than the best possible you can do
so you're basically overfeeding the
amount overfitting is this and
the whole point
okay we measure on the robustness of a
neuron of a mother by looking at the
sobolev seminom okay so you take the air
to in respect to the data of the
gradient of the jacobian okay so this
tells you on average how big a gradient
so with all of these this also there's a
bunch of flaws the first law is that
if you look at the robustness or the
robustness so this stuff sf uh
when it's small it means your voicemail
is bigger than robots so see this
memorization so you say overfit
uh your training data
okay
your robustness is going to be
at least this times
the square root of the number of points
in the training data
so it means that if you have a big data
set
and you do very well on train then
basically you cannot give us there's no
way you can interpolate to any point at
the others
which is very important
and for the different regimes you could
have represent results and that's
actually a law because if you plug
the
memorization against the robustness you
see looks like a
linear curve and all of the different
points are different experiments but
it's actually the law it's linear and
that's also like linear and different
colors correspond to different level
levels of noise in the labels
and
okay okay
also one interesting thing that came out
of this is so-called multiple descent in
uh
in in in robustness has anyone heard
about multiple decent generalization
so okay it's a it's a phenomenon by
which you know in classical statistics
if you have too many parameters compared
to data at one point you are going to
um
you you are going to over feed but if
you keep increasing the number of
parameters at one point your your
generation error is going to go again
down so this stuff uh that's what you
call uh multiple decisions i we
here observe this in
in robustness so basically if you look
at here so i'm looking at the ntk and
i'm looking at this so you can see this
code of sample
size more or less so you see it has this
kind of linear behavior and there are
certain points in which it goes to
infinity and these points correspond
exactly to the interpolation threshold
so the interpolation choices are when
the number of samples equal to either
the number of inputs or equal to the
number of healing you're born so these
two points are actually exactly analytic
and just for the experts actually these
correspond to like a singularities in
the trace of granola matrix exhibited a
random covariance matrix
and then you're going to have issues for
a number of samples wait a minute it
becomes square okay so this is this
display now everything is nonlinear
so yeah
and you have the same top stuff as that
and then maybe i'm going to end here so
um
just to again to to bounce off uh to to
bounce on the last the last example we
can consider three regimes so the
question is are they say examples where
are they from it could be from level
noise it could be from
lots of stuff so here let's try to feed
only noise so here there's only noise
okay and the row here is
large dimensional regime in which both
the sample size and the input dimension
go to infinity proportionately so the
ratio is held at home so if raw is big
it means you have more data than
dimensions and vice versa okay so when
the whole is too small
okay there's nothing so in this in this
not only case there's something
happening here so here the very red
stuff corresponds to the log of
something which is close to six is
almost infinity so there's a singularity
here we are very on robust because your
method is square and as you go up or
down it's so nice look at when you have
a noise
plus signal so here you have both noise
and signal as date as you have more data
compared to to to parameters actually
this stuff becomes big so the sf which i
sent has to be small for you to do
robots are pretty cool so in this
scenario the more data you have the less
robust you are
in the presence of noise because your
mother is going to try to memorize
the noise and you cannot do so in a
smooth way because it's nice and on this
i think i'm going to end this one or
half question i could take it thanks
questions
[Applause]
so we have time for half a question
and you will half answer
research lab
is now making a lot of contributions
regarding the transformation
[Music]
layers uh
transformer to detect to detect images
or to detect anything else now the
question is
if an adversarial attack may happen on
especially here it might
it might make the nether network focus
on other
things than the one that was planned to
focus on
so is the solution that you have to
provide not the solution i mean the
results that you have discussed
regarding the neural network can be
applied on attention layers
i see that's a good question so the
first part applies to everything
so they it applies to basically if your
classifier is uh using the london
features
no no the very first part of the token
will say like any classifier this
applies to anything even for the second
part it's a bit more tricky it's it's
very cheap so for example if you forget
about
uh attention let's just take no matter
how you should learn all the layers so
you see in my normal network some things
were random if you learn all the layers
with greater than the same i don't know
what to say so if you start putting
attention on this kind of stuff it just
goes uh
it's very complex you see actually
what's going to happen yes yeah so it's
it's really difficult actually
next
hello everyone
we're happy to participate in this
workshop
so
my thought would be about some tools and
uh and methods that have been introduced
during the previous years in order to
make uh neural networks more of us
it would be
optimistic
and uh so but new is that i don't have
so many images
okay so just a
reminder before we go deeper into the
presentation
so the accuracy we know um that is the
fraction of inputs that are correctly
classified by by so here i'm considering
neural network classifier
and there is a notion of robust accuracy
which is a fraction of inputs such that
the classifier keeps the same class
inside
the eltoban
centered at the input and with radius
luxury
so our goal is to increase
as much as possible the robust accuracy
because the brochure examples that have
been discussed
today have shown that
we may have a neural networks with high
accuracy but with very small
robust occurrence
so in the state of beyond uh
according to my knowledge there are
three main
approaches that have been proposed into
in order to reach this goal of
robustness
so the first one is called the sharia
training and has been discussed today so
we'll pass this slide
um
the second approach is based on formal
methods
so uh we know that formal methods are
very useful
in order to violate neural networks but
they can also be used
to train neural networks uh in such a
way to maximize uh the certified regions
of the end and
this approach works well however it is
not very scalable but um at least
comparing with the with that virtual
training it has
theoretical guarantees
so next i'm going to the third approach
in which i will spend more time which is
called randomized smoothing
so this idea was introduced
nearly two years ago
um so it is a very simple
uh idea so we start from a base
classifier f and then we um take
uh its smoothing by
gaussian
distribution with covariance sigma
square
the identities of the
iid
gaussian
samples with the same variance
and we take the expectation so for each
input x we add
uh so many um
circles from this gaussian distribution
and then
we take the average decision and this
defines the smoothing classifier
so in practice what the smoothing does
is that it reduces peaks so like here on
the left we have we have a classifier
which has uh so many types peaks and
these peaks actually um
lead to the creation of virtual examples
and by smoothing we reduce and we limit
the effect of these peaks and
we obtain
a more classified with
with the decision boundary which is more
speed
so the main result is that despite the
fact that we smooth with the gaussian
distribution we end up with the
classifier
the smoothed one which is
certified robust into
l2 bars with radius r and
so this
are here we can um explicitly compute it
and
so we are sure now that inside the l2
bars
of with these radius uh we are sure that
the
classifier the smoothing classifier is
100 is 100 percent robust and doesn't
change
the class of
of the input
so that's the main result regarding
randomized smoothing
then um
people are a market that we can improve
randomized smoothing in in the following
way so the remark that uh when the input
is far away from the decision boundary
we can allow ourselves to take
a higher higher variance and this
gives a rise to a bigger
certified buy so they
they proposed instead of fixing
the
the variance as we saw before they
proposed to for each input to look for
the optimal variance and this is done by
solving the equation um
so we we optimize the function r of x
sigma so
which we discussed before uh with
respect to to sigma
and this method um
uh showed better results than
classical and domestic
then another approach
in which people
started
smoothing with now with the
gaussian noise with a general covariance
matrix so
now we
will look for
a covariance matrix which is
so this is let's say more general than
fixing
a
covariance matrix which is diagonal and
all the terms on the regular are the
same
and now they um
so they look for a better covariance
matrix
and
so first of all
they computed the radius when we sample
from
from gaussian noise with the covariance
sigma here
and then they optimize this covariance
function with respect to sigma under the
uh the assumption that the the
the covariance matrix is the imminent
and if we uh assume this then we reduce
the problem to an optimization problem
on
on around
so comparing with the classical
randomized smoothing now this approach
is able to certify ellipsoids however
these ellipse widths are either
horizontal or vertical so it means that
the axis of the ellipsoids are always
parallel to the canonical basis of of
the space and it has been shown that
these ellipsoid
ellipsoids always contain the l2 bar
that we can certify with the classical
randomized method
so next we with um
so
before i go
to our work so one limitation of the of
the previous approach is that it is it
is not
um environment and the rotation because
if i have a data set like this then i
will find a good ellipsoid however if i
have a data set a little bit rotated
then um
the ellipse width that i will get
with the previous method is not is not
optimal
because i have this restriction to ever
take horizontal or vertical uh
so um
with
two colleagues so marcano don who is the
mathematician
geometer
and paul who was an internship with us
so we tackled the problem of maximizing
uh the function
which is the radius
of the input and the covariance matrix
we need to take and we um
so propose the formulation of this of
this problem
which is the following so first of all
we need to uh
we need to understand where the uh the
solution uh we are looking to
uh where it is where is the space to
which it belongs so when we look for a
covariance so this is a symmetric
positive and definite matrix and this
defines um a geometric space which which
is called romanian manifold
so riemannian manifold is
is the geometric space which is locally
equilibrium
and
so we were interested um
in the topology of this space
and fortunately there are a lot of works
on this uh on this space because it is
involved in many uh image processing
applications
and this for instance a very famous uh
distance called raw fisher which is
which originates from information
geometry that is very useful on this
space because it has
uh many uh and variance properties
uh so there is framework of image
optimization that has been developed um
on this space and unfortunately we also
uh worked on uh automatic
differentiation uh on this space uh
recently with uh
with so many people
and um
so we found many tools that are
available in the
all these tools have allowed us to make
optimization on
this space and
look to the most optimal solution
directly using this topology
so now i'm going to um the last slide so
slide here
so we evaluate we evaluated but we
didn't finish the evaluation so here are
some
preliminary results
so we uh we took
um
we took
a neural network and then applied um a
randomized looking with
with the different available methods
so um
and then we computed for each uh method
we computed the certified regions and uh
in order to compare uh
all these between all these methods we
searched for um the the radius of the uh
the maximal l2 blast that we can put
inside the certified uh region and what
we can remark uh so this figure
is that um the
uh the romanian junction based method it
always gives us
the highest
let's say the highest proportion of data
that are certified inside the l2 ball
of the radius that we we took at the
beach
it was a little bit quick
uh i have finished it so
if you have questions
[Applause]
so we have time for one question
i was wondering whether
it has a big impact on the sampling
process
because you have to choose uh at some
point you have to choose how many
samples you you generate and as you
change the shape
yes of the
yeah so is there any impact and uh
do you have ways to
i mean
relate the number of samples yes
yes this is very technical and it is
done with the hypothesis test there is a
hypothesis test but so when i say uh 100
percent actually it is 1990 yeah it's
when you have an infinite number of
samples yes
exactly yes so but you know how to
sample even yes this has been done yes
yes okay it's a little bit tricky but
there is a known number of samples for
each dimension
okay thank you so
thank you
images
and videos
every question
so i will
quickly speak about the research
direction
and that's higher business in
mca
and
[Music]
okay my
my goal was to to make you listen to
some example of adversarial examples in
audio
and especially
in speech recognition
because what we wondered at cga was okay
we are we are walking and speaking a lot
about uh examples
but we were wondering
about the physical the practical
feasibility of adversarial attacks
because what we want to consider is that
in some domains adversarial attacks are
critical and in some domains it's not so
credible
so in this example
we were playing some original file
with
the music
and
usually in adversarial example we are
saying that we are targeting
imperceptible
conservation of the signal
and unfortunately it's
started
if we if we listen yes
if we consider that
the the perturbation have been
have to be done in the physical world it
means that the perturbation have to be
robust
if we are contact if we have to quantize
the
the the signal for uh for a speaker
it has to be reduced to some noise in
the environment and also it has to be
removed
to noise and reverberation
and if we are considering those physical
consideration
the the the noise the perturbation that
we are introducing in the signal is not
so imperceptible
imperceptible it becomes
quite perceptible and quite noisy on the
signal
so it's not
there are no songs so
if you can see this
and so the credibility of an attack on
for example
in such a scenario for example we made
this demonstration to show
that
having an adversarial attack in audio is
that for example
if you are considering that for example
in waze
you have the you have your your your
wheel on the map
and as usual waze is proposing you some
alternative alternate rules
you can have some adversarial attacks
for example from the from the music you
are listening to
and in the if in the music you are
introducing some perseveration and the
perturbation at the perfect time can be
introduced
and it says okay take alternate routes
and that
your
your car is able to understand this
command
so your car can take autonomous cars of
course i you could recite this
your car can take the international so
of course it's possible but
it's not so easy to make and that has
higher attacks on them
in this kind of scenario
of course in images we know
we have a lot of examples in this
and in in this video we try to to make a
short
movie to explain
okay
where does the personal example can come
from
it's to explain to
general audience but we take the the
analogy between the
neural network
and this little game
and we are saying that when we train
some neural networks we are just trying
to
optimize in this game the position of
the
of the of the wood gear
and then when we are doing parameter
training
we are setting the position of the
inventory of the wood
and then
instead of falling in a completely
random
box at the end
it will fall on the correct box here
based on the initial position in this in
this analogy in this analogy what an
attack is
is somehow that you are slightly
modifying the first images and you are
exploiting some
random not ronda but
some chaotic behavior in the
the the fall of the board
and this
the fact that that the neural network is
doing some deterministic
decision
is creating the personal examples and
what were shown
in some work with uh affect you
who finished in sp
one year ago
whether
when you are considering deterministic
decision you have a way to fool the
network
and a good solution to
to make the network the neural network
focused with that style attacks is to
introduce some randomization in the
process
and that's why we are considering as a
generic defense
the the the
the way to defend against adversary and
adversarial attacks is to introduce the
randomized classifier which is a
generalization of from the western thing
and in which we introduce some noise
either on the inputs
or
in in the
or in the
in the different layers of the
of the neural networks
so in ca we have
quite a lot of applications of
neural networks let's say
machine learning in general and neural
networks in particular
and for example we are doing in
spectrometer analysis some estimation of
concentrations
and identification of some
components
right now we have shown that neural
networks are able to
outperform historical methods
but it introduces some some weaknesses
of course there's a
we need everyone in this room downstairs
because it's a conclusion they've been
waiting for you for now 20 minutes
it's a political
option i would say that's downstairs
it's to
show that they can have trust in not ai
but us
it's a political person so please come
now i'm sorry to interrupt you it's
really really important from the
political point of view for the fundings
which is quite important that you get
this
i'm sorry again
[Applause]
[Music]